we should never ever despair from a las
merci
we should never turn away from a las
merci like I mentioned if a las marias
encompassed everything the Shaitaan
knows de but even then he has not given
up he still wants you to enter the pits
of the fire of hell with him so he
hasn't given up even though he knows a
las Mercy has encompassed everything
even the fact that he was given a
respite until the day of judgment is a
form of Allah's mercy to him
so what planned planned as the Shaitaan
used for us to for there to be a barrier
between us and Allah Smurfs II who can
tell me to despair from the Rama of
Allah like I mentioned for us to be be
the ones that turn away he said no I
don't want it war for us to think that
Allah is not going to forgive me we've
taken ayat and a Haditha show us the
greatness of Allah Smurfs II and this is
why this in this ayah and in this surah
allah dedicates an entire verse to
remind us constantly that he is the lord
of forgiveness and compassion and mercy
this is why we should never despair from
a las mercy as he says
googly-eye body alladhina ostrov o allah
enthusiam lattaker atamira Mattila in
allah of Ferelden obey jamia in the
holder for Rahim as Allah says o My
servants who have been wasteful and they
have wronged themselves and they have
transgressed against their own souls
latter cannot Amira Mattila do not
despair from the mercy of Allah because
Allah he forgives every sin and every
mistake showing us the greatness of
Allah Smurfs E and how much love and
compassion he has for us the process
solemn said if the believer
was to know the the punishments of Allah
he will think that nobody is going to
enter into paradise and if the
disbeliever was to know what Allah had
with his mercy then he will think
nobody's going to enter the fire of Hell
showing us how vast Allah's mercy is but
at the same time we have that balance
where we fear his punishment as well we
don't say I'm going to do whatever I
whatever I want and Allah is going to be
merciful he's going to be waiting for me
with his mercy no it doesn't mean that
it means we try our best to worship
Allah and we understand there's going to
be times where we're going to slip up
and we're going to fall into sin and
fall victim to the Shaitaan and his
plans and his plots
however we when we do fall into those
sins we have humility and we acknowledge
we've made a mistake and we turn back to
Allah and we seek his forgiveness and we
seek his mercy and we never give up we
never give up in Allah
mercy and one important point here is
that when we see somebody falling into
sin we never looked down upon them and
we don't judge them and we don't say
that person is barred from the mercy of
Allah or laws not going to forgive that
person the process of selling himself
spoke about this where he said in Roger
on Carla a la ilaha illaallah full on
that a man said by Allah Allah is not
going to forgive someone saw that this
person is barred and he's restricted
from Allah's mercy then Allah said when
allah - allah called mandala deity allah
allah allah allah fear allah fallen for
anicca dukkha for toll if Allah were to
a Malik process of
in this hadith Allah said who is there
that has the audacity to speak on my
behalf
and restrict my mercy tell this person
that I have forgiven the person he said
was never ever going to see attain my
forgiveness and I have made your actions
null and void subhanAllah showing us the
the severity of the sin of arrogance and
looking down upon others and thinking
our lives not going to forgive others
thinking that we are better than them
process enough said this one the means
to have our deeds null and void why is
them why do the deeds become null and
void for the person who says Allah is
not going to forgive so and so it's a
level of arrogance where he thinks he's
will be accepted what else it undermines
a Las mercy he is restricting the mercy
of Allah something which he has no right
to do as the creation he's speaking
about Allah without any knowledge
without any understanding and he's doing
the work of the Shaitaan where he's
helping or he's making this person think
you should turn away from Allah's mercy
should carry on sinning because the
doors of Mercy are closed for you and
sometimes we don't need another person
to do this for us we do it to ourselves
where we think I've done such and such
mistake who have made this mistake Allah
is not going to forgive me the fact that
you have that guilt inside you the fact
that you are conscience of your Lord it
shows that there is some goodness there
and Allah will forgive you and you
should never ever give up
in the mercy of Allah and subhanAllah if
you were to make a mistake in this dunya
and you went and you did something that
your mother told you you shouldn't do
and you did it and then you she came
home and you tell her this is why I've
done you acknowledge what you've done
and she'd uh she'd always accept you
with open arms
she'd always accept you with open arms
that's in this dunya we look at what
happens when allah he accepts somebody's
forgiveness when we turned to him with
repentance and we seek his help there's
a number of things that happen the first
one is that allah forgives the sin no
matter how great it may be no matter how
great you think that sin is allows doors
of mercy are always open and he will
always seek he will always give you that
forgiveness if you seek it from him when
you make tawba you cut yourself off from
that sin you feel guilt you have an
intention to never ever go back to that
sin you make a sincere tawba you place a
barrier between yourself and that sin
Allah will always forgive you no matter
how great that sin may seem in a hadith
Qudsi the process of them tells us that
Allah said yep no edema in occur matter
attorney or a Joe Tony Hoffer to laka
Allah McKenna Minka voila Upali process
alum said Allah said o son of Adam as
long as you seek my forgiveness and you
make duaa and you have hope I will
forgive you for your sins no matter how
great they are and I do not care and the
hadith carries on speaking about how
Allah says if you were to come to me
with the with this earth full of sins
and then you make you made tawba and
made his dig far and you saw a lot of
repentance and you took active steps to
stop yourself from that sin
Allah will turn to us with forgiveness
showing us the vast mercy of Allah so
the first thing that we learned we make
tawba is that Allah he accepts that
table and he forgives that sin no matter
how great you think it may be the second
thing when it comes to understanding a
loss mercy when we seek His forgiveness
and we seek his mercy is that it is
there 24/7 throughout the day and
throughout the night there's nothing
which can restrict allows mercy and we
learn this from the hadith of the
process Salim said in Allah to Allah the
opposite Orianna who belay Lee Lee a
tuber moosian aha Allah he extends his
hand in the night time for those people
that sin throughout the day and
throughout the daytime he extends his
hand for those people that sin
throughout the night and this happens
every single day up until the Sun rises
from the the west meaning the time in
Yama Yama is established so throughout
the day and throughout the night
Allah is hand of mercy and forgiveness
is extended to us from that which
happens when we seek lost forgiveness is
that he is happy for us so upon Allah we
have wronged ourselves and we have gone
against the rules that he has set their
force we have gone against his guidance
and we go back and we humble ourselves
and we seek His forgiveness not only
does he accept this forgiveness not only
is he there to forgive us day and night
but subhanAllah he is happy for us the
process of them said Allah after AHA
btob up de Mena Hideko zakat Allah by
hereby eerie rocketed Allah who feared
in fala process solemn said Allah is
more happy when we seek forgiving
and make repentance he's more happy than
when if one of you was travelling and he
was on a camel and he had everything on
that camel and he loses it and then he
finds it again you could imagine the
happiness this person is going to have
Qasim said Allah is more happier than
that man and today we can understand
this imagine if you're driving and
you're on the motorway you go into a
city you never been to before and you
stop at a service station and you come
out and the cars disappeared and
everything of value is in there your
wallet your phone everything everything
is in that car and it disappears and you
start asking people and there's no
there's no sign of this car whatsoever
then how have the blue you remember you
parked is something else and you see
that car the happiness that you would
have in your heart or it just appears
magically the happiness that you have in
your heart Allah is more happy than that
when you seek his forgiveness and
subhanAllah it's not like Allah gains
anything from this Toba that we seek so
why is he happy is happy for the fact
that we are bettering ourselves and we
are attaining happiness for atoning for
our sins and having our sins washed away
because Allah does not gain anything
from our our tobin our repentance or
other we are the ones that gain and
another thing that happens that shows us
the vastness of Allah's mercy and how
great his mercy truly is is that not
only does he accept the Toba not only
does he show us mercy he wipes away
those sins and he's there day and night
to forgive us and he's happy for our
forgiveness so pan Allah he turns our
bad deeds into our good deeds
subhanallah if he was just to forgive us
for our transgressions that would be
enough but he gives and he gives and he
gives and we learn in surah Furqan Allah
speaks about the the Seifert of the
Habad Oh Rahman the attributes of his
true faithful servants he says element
AB Rama Navami Liholiho
for Allah EKU Badillo say yeah our team
has a lot
what can a locker for or AHIMA Allah
says those people that make tawba
they seek His forgiveness and they truly
repent and they believe and they
accompany this true belief with
righteous deeds they do these three
things they make tawba
they believe that do righteous deeds
with them they show that they've turned
away from that sin it's not just an
empty I'm sorry
no but they understand that this was
something which was not befitting for
them to fall into they taken active
steps to move away from that Allah says
you but the law say yeah our team has a
not Allah he turns their bad deeds into
good deeds for them Subhan Allah showing
us the great vastness of our Lord al
imam hasan a buddy who died in the year
110 after the process of Psalms Hydra he
said about this verse Abdullah home
alone analysts say he am Allah sorry
that from Allah Smurfs II is that he has
changed and he turns their bad deeds
into good deeds Abdullah meshuggaas
Larsen and he has turned their sherek
after their tawba into sincerity and a
true belief in Allah o Allah who built
for Julia Shannon and the indecency that
they would make before Allah he turns
that into the reward of being being
chaste and having chastity abu de
l'homme Allah will cover he is Lama
and he was covered that they had fallen
to before Allah gives them the reward of
of an Islam of believing in Allah